[موسيقى]
أريد لبناتي أن يعرفن ويتذكرن
الرجل المذهل الزوج والأب الذي
كان الله يعلم أنهما لا يمكن أن يكونا على هذه
الأرض بدون بعضهما البعض ، كان
عليهما إحضارهما إلى المنزل معًا في الجنة ، عزيزتي أنت
تعتني بأمرنا  شيشي وأنا حصلت على مربية
بيبي وكوكو ، ما زلنا أفضل فريق
نحبه ونفتقدك بوو بوو
وقد يرقد كل من جيجي بسلام ويستمتع في
الجنة حتى نلتقي مرة أخرى في يوم من الأيام
نحبكما ونفتقدكما إلى الأبد و
أمي دائمًا ، كان
هذا الحب لفانيسا هو الطاقة
لحياته ، قصة معينة
تجسد عمق حب كوبي
لفانيسا ، قال إنه لم يكن ينام
كثيرًا في الليل لأنه كان
يفتقد Vee والفتيات كثيرًا أثناء
تواجده بعيدًا.  أراد أن يعيش في
حبه لفانيسا ، لذلك في الليل تحت
سماء مقمرة ، تعهد بتعليم نفسه عن طريق
الأذن للعب أول حركة
لسوناتا ضوء القمر لبيتهوفن التي
اتصل بها كوبي في صباح
اليوم التالي ولعبني في
الصباح التالي.  التابع  في الأسبوع
كان لديه سيد القطعة بالكامل
[موسيقى]
نحن كوبي براينت ماتت قطعة مني
، وبينما أنظر في هذه الساحة في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، ماتت قطعة منك وإلا
فلن تكون هنا ،
فهذه هي الذكريات التي علينا
أعيش معه ونتعلم منه ،
أعدك من هذا اليوم فصاعدًا ، سأعيش
مع ذكريات معرفة
أن لدي أخًا صغيرًا حاولت مساعدته في
كل مكان يمكنني أن أرقد
بسلامه يا فتى صغير قلت كوبي ليس هناك أنا في
الفريق  وقال كوبي إنني أعرف ولكن هناك
amia no Mamba ، لقد تم أخذك بعيدًا
عنا بعيدًا جدًا ، كان الفصل التالي من
حياتك قد بدأ للتو ، ولكن الآن حان
الوقت لمواصلة
إرثك سأعتني بالأشياء هنا سأكون  تأكد
من تعليم ناتاليا بيانكا والطفل كابري
كل تحركاتك وأعدك بأنني لن
أعلمهم تقنيات الرمية الحرة الخاصة بي ، لكن
في الوقت الحالي أشعر بالراحة في الواقع لأننا
نتحدث عن كوبي وجيجي
يمشيان إلى أقرب ملعب كرة سلة
سيظهر لنا كوبي  يحكم لومومبا
اليوم وجيجي قريبًا  جماهير Kobe أو Heaven's
MVP أحبك يا رجلي حتى نلتقي
مرة أخرى
[تصفيق]